have you ever wanted a robot to clean
and mop your house meet the ecovax dbot
X1 Omni thanks to Best Buy for
partnering with me on this video I've
only ever seen separate vacuum and mop
robots but having this do everything all
in one is super impressive it has two
main components the docking station and
the actual cleaning robot these are the
mopping pads that magnetically attach to
the bottom along with these side
sweepers that assist with getting all
the extra dirt in the corners when
vacuuming there are internal water tanks
one for the dirty and other for the
Clean Water this will auto fill the tank
inside the d-bot and refill as necessary
while mopping connecting your deebot to
Wi-Fi and the app is one of the most
important parts to get all of the
benefits right now I started the first
mapping session that gets the full
layout of my home after a few cleans
it'll continually learn your home and
you can update the layout to make
Corrections you can select certain
sections of your home to clean at any
given time and d-bot is also voice
activated it even has a built-in camera
this is passcode activated for security
but look how cool this is to get this or
other robot vacuums check out the Best
Buy link the ultimate Tech destination